Rebecca comes to us live from standby.
Quick show of hands.
Who in this room has actually been to the standby yet?
It's so up.
Oh my gosh,
me too.
To love it.
It's super good.
It's unbelievable.
Thank you so much for being a part of sort of the revitalization that's
happening with all of Detroit and the eateries as well.
Um,
big as you can tell.
Crowd favorite.
I didn't even realize that many people had been there already,
but um,
a couple more cool and interesting facts about Rebecca and then I promise I'll
stop talking and let you to do more talking.
So she's California native.
I think probably the most notable thing we'll talk a lot about today is that you
were a contestant on the 12th season of top chef.
Amazing.
So exciting.
She has moved here to recently this summer sometime.
Yeah,
I moved in June.
In June from Chicago,
right?
Yes.
So you were in Chicago,
you were head chef at uh,
the Virgin Hotel.
Yes.
And um,
you came here with your husband who is also working in Detroit as a chef at the
apparatus room.
Yes.
Station hotel.
For the foundation or Tom?
Tom is his name.
Yup.
And um,
you have a couple for babies.
I just collected.
I don't understand.
Oh,
you have another one?
Last I heard you had three fur babies,
now you're at fault.
Four,
four.
And I have a very small apartment right now,
especially when you have four creatures.
But that happens.
That was used to it now.
He used to get so mad at me for bringing stuff home.
That's the way it was.
It was two dogs and a cat before.
What is it now?
Now I have three dogs.
Cat.
Wow.
That's it.
And then it's a good story.
That was funny.
Well,
can we hear it?
Sure.
So we have another restaurant or bar called the skip and about,
and we only serve the Mexican style coke,
the small ones and the in the glass jars.
And we got completely slammed one weekend we had like a big Dj set and Adidas
had like taken over the whole beltway.
And so they're like,
chef,
you're one the only ones where the car can you please go to honeybee and get
some more soda?
And I was like,
sure.
So I go to honeybee at like eight o'clock at night and a big giant puppy dog is
running around the roads,
like freaked out.
And I was like,
oh,
he got out of somebodies yard.
So I pull over and these other people tried to get him.
He ran away from them and I was like,
come here puppy.
He was huge.
Um,
jumped in my car.
He was beat up pretty good.
Um,
but it was a Saturday night and none of the rescues could take him.
So I was like,
okay,
you're either going to like fit in this weekend with the dogs or you're going to
try to kill my docksin.
Um,
cause I didn't know he was a fight.
Darger anything.
It was just like,
all right.
Um,
so we gave him a bath and fed him and kind of hung out with him for a little bit
and he never went away.
He adapted.
He did.
So now I have a a 90 pound baby.
And what kind of dog is he?
He is a lab mastiff pit.
Bull Mix.
Oh Wow.
That's,
but he is just,
and we should've named him Stimpy cause he's totally sweet but kind of stupid
and like just happy.
He just wants to play all the time.
It just has no idea how big he is.
What did you name him?
Um,
his name is Busby,
which is like totally not a normal name,
but my husband has been amassing the Manchester United greatest tips players of
all time history with all of my pets.
So my cat's name is gigs after Ryan Giggs.
My um,
American bulldogs name is Rooney from Wayne Rooney.
And then now I have sir Busby who was like there,
I don't know if he's like hall of famer manager something or other and I was
like,
okay,
perfect.
That's one of our clients actually.
Chevrolet sponsors Manchester.
Yeah.
With them.
There is an interesting,
their hugest fan lives downtown.
Can we tell them that?
Totally freak out.
It's my world.
It's my world into trade.
I think you're probably realizing that,
that you can't walk down the street and not know someone or someone knows
someone from high school or college.
Right.
She's the other day.
And I was like,
okay,
everybody is like everybody,
I had all the five people I know we're here.
Well let's start there.
So we're,
we are going to talk a lot more about top chef and end of year for babies.
But let's start there.
Let's very,
very interesting to us and,
and,
and there's some timely news happening right now cause I don't know if you saw
but Google just announced a couple of weeks ago.
We're making the move officially down to Detroit next year.
Yeah,
we're excited too.
So tell us,
um,
having not been being a California native and not necessarily a Michigander to
train name it,
tell us what being a part of the Detroit rebirth has been like for you.
Um,
I love it.
I have been coming to Detroit for the past four years.
Um,
actually what's pretty funny,
four years ago we stayed at the Cadillac cause my bridal shower was here cause
we have,
hi,
my husband has relatives in Michigan and so I had never gotten to meet a bunch
of them.
So that was how I met all of them.
And that was the first time I'd ever really been downtown Detroit.
And at that point it was a little bit scary.
Yeah.
And it wasn't bad.
Like I think the guy,
we've,
we went and had dinner at roast and we were like,
where can we go for cocktails?
And like,
I was like,
you shouldn't leave the hotel.
And I was like,
well,
okay,
fine.
He's like,
no one's really bad idea.
That's just four years ago.
And now I recognize the church that I drove by and it's completely like,
it's right across the street from Little Caesar's pizza arena and nothing was
there.
And now it's like Woodward has grown up and all of these beautiful buildings,
it gets completely unrecognizable from what it was four years ago.
And right after the show I started doing dinners at revolver and steadily every
six months I have done dinner at revolver.
So I've been coming ahead and watching it grow up and I tried to get him to move
here like two years ago.
Um,
and you guys probably didn't know this but um,
Michigan is huge horse country and I grew up showing horses so I know a lot,
a lot of breeders and trainers are here and I was like,
cool,
I can like I can still show horses if we move
to Detroit.
That's funny you did an interview with someone recently where you said that a
big part of moving to downtown Detroit meant that you could staple your horses
or you could have your horses,
which I didn't think that that would be,
it doesn't seem realistic.
And I live here,
I'm from here.
So where do you stable them?
Tell us a little bit about that.
Quite Metamora but like,
uh,
okay.
Um,
right before I always forget where his family's from.
Port here on there is to like have the top Arabian horse trainers in the u s up
there.
So it's literally a 45 minute drive from downtown if it's not traffic time.
Did you have your horses in Chicago?
No,
most of my horses are in Arizona and in California.
Right.
So I have western pleasure horses and renters and they aren't with my best,
one of my best friends down in Scottsdale.
And Are you,
do you do shows with them as well?
That's so interesting.
Yeah.
So,
but up here there's a lot of English horses and I love English and writing hunt,
so I'm gonna get myself a half Arabian and very cool.
Yeah.
Very cool.
Well let's,
let's
really interesting,
you do hear that a lot when we get people transplants as we call him from other
cities who have given up a swanky life in New York or given up a lot of property
out west to come to Detroit,
that there are some sort of creature comforts that did.
This city does an offer side of your stature.
And so I think that that's really interesting that horses is,
your passion into trade seems to be still a good fit for you.
So yes,
great.
You kind of,
you get the best of both worlds.
Like we can't really live too far away from a major metropolitan area.
That's just our jobs don't translate well to the other kind of food they're both
of us do.
So it works out really well that we can have a property and have animals and I
have always had cows and pigs and horses and all that stuff and now I can
actually do that and afford to buy a house.
It isn't the size of a postage stamp.
Yeah,
it's a little expensive down there right now.
Well,
okay.
So in that same theme of Detroit,
um,
well let's talk about standby.
Standby James Beard award nominee right now,
um,
typically known as a bar that leads to a restaurant slash bar that leads with
really well known,
strong alcoholic drinks,
bar drinks.
That's kind of how you guys have your reputation building right now.
Tell us as a chef coming into a restaurant with a bar with that type of
reputation,
how it's been challenging for you or how you've been able to either a compliment
that or you know,
what,
what you see from a negative and a positive standpoint.
Um,
I thought it was a great project and I came from having five restaurants under
my hat to having one that was really focused was really nice.
Um,
and I could bring the food to the same level as the cocktails and my job was to
get it there,
get us more organized so we can continue to work on other projects and expand
the company.
Yeah.
What,
what are you most proud of that you've done it?
Um,
just that like consistency,
I think consistency and that like we don't have a disparity between the food and
the cocktails.
Like before we had,
we have a $20 drink on the menu,
but
it's like everything is,
is a lot snacky are,
and that's just,
they just hadn't found the right fit of person to kind of do that.
And to me,
I'm like,
standby is a cocktail bar that has great food.
It's not a restaurant that has great cocktails.
So that's something that I try to keep it everybody's mind that I'm there to
compliment the food and to help us do other things.
Yeah,
you have quite an extensive background as a chef.
Let's talk a little bit about the APP chefs.
So,
um,
top chef,
I think it's what all of us know,
that's how you got your chops,
but is there some other way that,
do you think top chef kind of has out shadowed something else in your life
you're really proud of that got you to where you are now?
Or would you credit top chef for that?
I think I did top shelf cause it was just an easy point in my life to be able to
do that.
We were really fortunate to where my,
the company that I was working with Trencherman and the Heisler group where it
was like,
yes,
do it please.
And I was like,
I don't know.
I'm not like,
that's not my deal.
I didn't really need to do that stuff.
Um,
but I think what I had kind of done to get there before was a good lead up to
it.
Um,
it certainly wasn't my favorite thing that I've ever done,
but it,
I don't regret it.
I never wanted to regret doing it.
And they asked me like they begged and begged,
begged me to do it.
And I was like,
alright,
I'll do it.
Just not a very good social person.
We could afford that.
Man.
I kept my mouth quiet a lot,
which was one of the reasons why they were like,
you're,
you're very quiet.
I'm like,
well,
because some of the things that come out of my mouth are very nice.
Like I just like,
well,
you're just like,
you're stuck in a weird situation.
And I think the most frustrating thing for me was I was like,
and the same thing with James.
Have we both agreed on this one?
We were like,
good food takes time.
And that's what they take away from you.
They take away the two most important things about being a really good chef that
really cares about your food is time and the ability to pick your ingredients.
One of the biggest things about our job is sourcing the best ingredients and
local ingredients that we can.
So it's a little bit like you never feel like you're putting your best foot
forward for somebody that you completely admire.
Like you're cooking for Java pen and you're like,
wow,
I just ran through whole foods that we ravage like three days ago.
It's a three day weekend.
We know they didn't get any fresh orders because we know how everything flows in
and out of these places and I'm going to put this in front of 7 million people
and I'm cooking on a stove in an apartment near you and this is awesome.
Here you go.
Thank you.
He's just like,
oh.
But for the most part you were given some really positive feedback on that show.
Oh yeah.
I had a good time.
I mean I met some amazing people.
Um,
it's definitely like nobody knows what you go through except for like the 15 of
you that are there.
So we're all pretty,
pretty close,
pretty tight.
Which was fun.
Well,
you met some amazing people.
There's a lot of celebrity chefs and a lot of celebrities really in general that
you came across with on that season.
Who is your favorite?
Who stands out to you as someone you were most glad to meet?
Or newer?
But I think it was pretty over it by the time we had to meet people.
Would you say one of the other contestants?
It was really fun to like be in the chairs set and do an meet norm and do all
that stuff.
And then he came to my restaurant like four months later and we weren't allowed
to talk about it because we had the,
it had an air yet and he was like,
I love your jacket.
I was like,
thanks.
I thought that was super funny.
Oh my gosh.
That's awesome.
That's very cool.
He had,
that was,
that was a great one,
but it was one that much.
So post life top chef.
Um,
was there one of the other contestants that you stayed in touch with?
I think we know the answer to this.
You already mentioned a couple of names,
but someone you stayed in touch with that you've really felt you built a network
around.
Um,
but,
well James and I are really close.
James.
Yeah.
Um,
May and I talk pretty much all the time.
Carrie Ann and I are still really good friends.
We were roommates.
Um,
George and I were really close.
We hung out together a lot after we got eliminated.
It was really fun to get eliminated because you're stuck in this house and
you're like,
wow,
I don't have to do anything besides like entertain myself.
What would you do once you got eliminated?
I'm always,
we know this when you get eliminated a ton of trouble for telling you this,
but I don't really care.
Like I'm like,
what are you gonna do to me?
I've got nothing but basically rented out like a residence inn and we all got
our own apartment and you get like,
you get so much money a week for food and stuff.
So we took over the pool and we barbecued every day.
Yeah.
And then we would perfect.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
We had a great time and it was summer.
It was like none of us have ever been able to be off,
have this much time off in our life and to not have to like run a check on the
restaurant or do something else.
Or like every year as a chef,
you're always just on.
So it was really awesome to be like,
wow,
this is like what actual vacation feels like.
It's like celebrity spring break.
Totally accepted.
We were like,
you guys should have had the camera's here.
Like we snuck out and went to Karaoke and James is a huge karaoke,
a holic.
That was hysterical.
I had a great time.
How Fun.
Yeah,
we had a great time.
Well okay so,
so top chef,
the rebirth of Detroit,
you're,
you have so many interesting layers to,
I could,
I don't even know where to start,
but one of the other things I do want to talk about because you're at Google and
there's a number of things that we prioritize here.
Worklife
balance is one of them.
Hearing that you have your horses here with you at which affords you a better
life is awesome cause we can all relate to that.
But um,
talk to us a little bit about something else that's very important here at
Google.
And we have a group called women at and a part of our,
our initiative behind that is just to kind of like uncover truths and,
and do a lot of sort of sharing of our lives and things that make being a woman
in a technology field at a very large corporation with a big reputation.
It's not always easy.
I cannot imagine almost a tougher industry then being a chef,
a professional chef and the industry that you're in and being female and leading
that.
So talk to us a little bit about some of the challenges or if there's one big
one that stands out for you in your journey as a female chef amongst what I
think is probably a pretty big boys' club.
It is a huge boys' club.
I just never put up with it and I didn't ever kind of realize that it wasn't
going to put up with it until I was at Michael Mina.
And,
um,
I always just kind of focused on doing a really good job.
And if I knew,
I knew I needed to get better and I was looking over at what other people are
doing and I just made sure,
I just made sure I worked harder than everybody else.
Um,
but there was a couple of people that like you always run across some guys that
don't want you there.
Right.
Um,
especially,
um,
this is gonna sound really terrible,
but like there's a lot of foreign chefs that we work with,
but that is not,
it's not a big women crossover yeah.
Into their workforce.
So they were like,
get out and you're not conforming to whatever our cultural program is.
And I was like,
dude,
if you want to go toe to toe back here,
fine.
Bring it on chef style.
I don't care.
Yeah.
You're not going to get in the way of me not doing my job,
but I'm also not going to let you treat me like garbage or throw my stuff away
or oh,
would they do that?
Oh yeah.
Like kitchen sabotage is,
oh yeah,
I need that pot.
Like,
oh yeah,
like completely,
oh,
that's horrific.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Oh,
I did not a big deal.
I love that you say that.
You just,
you just won't stand for,
and it's,
I know,
dude,
like if you touch my shit again,
I'm going to burn you out.
It's like prison rules,
man.
Like you get there early,
get all of your stuff,
and if you continue to try to take my stuff,
I'm going to put a spoon on the flat top and I'm going to hold it to your hand.
Don't yet.
But as soon as you like,
they figure out that like you're not going to put up with it.
Like the stuff stops.
Yeah.
Wow.
So it's,
that's,
that's amazing.
And actually even more a terrifying then the way I thought you would describe
it.
So good for you.
I love,
I love again,
I just love that you have,
you know,
the balls to just say,
I'm not going to stand for this and I will sabotage you right back so you don't
belong here.
You belong here.
Don't you're good for the city.
Like,
am I going to put up with that?
So then,
uh,
the next obvious question is two chefs in one family,
incredibly difficult back to the work life balance thing.
But how do you and Tom Make it work?
Cause it's nights,
it's weekends,
it's early mornings.
Do you,
you find that that presents itself a challenge or is it easier?
It was probably a little harder when we were first
together cause we didn't really have super control of our schedules.
But no,
we both kind of make the schedule and we both really understand that.
Like if something happens,
if you have something going on in a Sunday,
of course you have to work on Sunday,
that's,
that's okay.
Um,
but we try to make sure that we have like Sunday or Monday or both days off a
week so we can actually see each other.
I feel like it makes us appreciate each other more because we are not on top of
each other at all.
Like we leave by nine 30 10 in the morning,
one of us will come home and walk the dogs and hang out with the dogs during the
day and then we don't get home until 12 o'clock.
Wow.
So,
and then repeat rinse,
wash,
repeat.
Absolutely.
Uh,
who's the better chef de totally depends.
We do totally different styles of food you'd tell us about that.
So he is like ultra fine dining all the time.
And I did that for a long time and I was just like,
I don't need this in my life.
Um,
I remember like a pinnacle moment,
we were actually here two years ago doing Saber Detroit and Tom was,
um,
paired up with Luciano from Bucko and I was like,
just because your restaurant's name is 16 does not mean you need 16 garnishes.
Whoa.
I think I'm one of the only people that can get away with saying that.
And there was like sometimes like,
you know,
like Chenelle says more when you look in the mirror before you go out the door,
it takes something off.
Yeah.
Trail applies here,
but that's,
that's his style.
So you were telling how then as a little bit more simplistic.
Yeah,
I just like,
and that's kind of how I take standby is,
um,
I'm like,
well,
what tastes good?
What's going to,
to me it doesn't have to like I don't want to it to be more complicated than it
has to be.
To me kind of less is more.
And let the,
let the stuff speak for itself.
Right.
So you didn't answer us though.
Who Do you think is the better?
The better?
I don't know.
I mean,
so he's 10 years older than me,
so technically he would be that way.
If you ask who makes dinner every day?
Is it you?
Actually I was on my list of questions.
So what,
what's your go to recipe at home?
Not home really ever at the same time,
but it never had to cook something or you had friends coming over.
What's your go to if we friends coming over?
That's a tough one.
It's usually a holiday,
so whatever holiday food I like totally nerd out over the holidays so I'll go
like go crazy that way.
And we both loved Thanksgiving so thanksgiving becomes like a giant raucous of
stuff.
I'm like,
who are we going to feed?
And we have like five.
I was going to say
working,
but
we cook really simply at home.
Like Tom Loves me,
real meatloaf and Paul Rose.
So that's like basically I make at home.
It's like completely not what people think.
He's a,
he's more of like a,
a fluffy,
luxurious 16 course meal or 16 sort of big,
but he likes you.
He likes just like good home cook.
Totally.
Like he cooks breakfast every Sunday morning and that's like the most cooking
that he does at home.
And then I usually do,
do dinner and stuff like that.
But yeah,
we're totally symbol at home.
We cook like everybody else.
Do you use any social media channels or youtube maybe for any kind of recipe
guidance or cooking or
no.
Um,
my Instagram is full of darn pictures,
which is totally,
totally disappointing for some people.
But yeah,
I have a docksin and I think he's won.
So he posts pictures about him all the time.
Um,
but no,
generally youtube by watching makeup tutorials and get out of like chef world.
Okay.
So you,
you actually,
you're not using youtube to sort of perfect your culinary craft.
You're using that more
for your personal yeah,
well better.
I do point my sous chefs and stuff to a channel called chef steps and they are
awesome.
So if you're like,
okay,
I suck at boiling eggs,
they will show you like four ways to like hard boil and peel and egg.
And they also do a lot of like molecular gastronomy and like they do some really
high end things,
but um,
they have some really fun stuff.
Like if you're like,
okay,
I want to figure out how to make hollandaise sauce and put it in an Isi gun and
blow it up.
Like,
all right,
cool.
There's a video,
the whole team.
Well then who is your,
you said you use makeup tutorials.
Who's your favorite youtube create her for that.
Oh my God.
I have like a million of those.
I like to watch them all and no one stands out.
I Watch Bailey Syrian a lot and um,
Michelle phone,
I don't watch Michelle fonder.
I used to,
but,
um,
Jaclyn Hill does a good job and um,
a couple of girls over in the UK.
I really like,
it's a little bit more of a natural look.
Yeah.
There's a lot of makeup going on these days and I'm like,
I don't have time for that.
I also don't want it to like,
we sweat a lot in the kitchen and like nobody feels good,
but like did our 10 and you look like you've jumped out of a swimming pool.
You're like,
wow,
I just went upstairs to the dining room and I look like I have either been
crying or at a Marilyn Manson concert.
Not a good look for anybody.
Well,
you listen to,
to fall
everything I've ever seen it on TV.
So it's one of my best friends is to makeup.
She always does make fixes me before I have to go on.
Was she in town?
She travels all the time.
She's the lead,
make a traveling artist for the UFC,
so she covers it.
Bruises mostly makes the girls beautiful.
But um,
yeah,
she's the one who's always like,
okay,
hold on.
You mentioned you and Tom when you are together,
maybe Mondays or Tuesdays you have date nights.
Is there outside of the foundation hotel or standbys or a favorite hotspot you
guys like to go to in Detroit?
We always try to go someplace different.
Yeah cause there's like everybody,
so
many friends who have restaurants and so many places to go,
which is really awesome.
It's kind of nicer to go out here then it wasn't in Chicago cause this was just
like everybody here has a purpose and instead of like,
oh I decided I'm gonna open a Chinese restaurant.
That's cool.
All right.
That's not what you do.
Yeah.
So we basically try to hit
all of our friends places and then anything that's been around for more than 50
years.
Like we totally love restaurants that have been around for a million years.
Even if they're like,
because it's funny and like totally old and nostalgic.
And the more,
the funnier the better like class and stay camp.
Totally.
Like can't wait to go there.
Like it's totally on our list.
No,
because they closed on the one of the days that were always off.
So yeah,
like the best place that we love,
places like that.
Anything that's kind of funny.
One of our first dates was at book in a Pepo cause it was funny and I'm like
this is like the weirdest goal.
But we were like,
we want to go someplace and order the nicest Keon d on the menu and have it be
one of those stupid basket one
to do it.
And so this is like,
because all the cafe,
yeah that wasn't well and where were we?
We were in Vegas so there wasn't a Roma cafe there and we didn't realize they
put us downstairs in the basement because we must have looked like trouble.
But there was these private party of deaf people.
It's where like,
it's really quite what is going on.
And then we like dawned on us like half way through,
I remember like,
oh they're at a private party and they stuck us in their room and they're all
signing like no wonder there's folk music or anything.
Like we were with this kind of sitting there like things going on.
This is your first date.
Yeah.
I was wondering if first days
that'd be tough.
Temped to connect.
It was quiet hysterical.
We had been had like plenty to drink before then.
So yeah it was,
it was super funny.
What about in Detroit?
I said class in steak house,
but what's your favorite old place?
50 plus years old.
Anywhere that you could name off.
We loved the going to the London chophouse that has been reopened and redone.
That was really,
really good and it's fun and going up to the cigar bars.
Really cool.
And um,
so so far that's been kind of the number one.
Like we love to go to Jacoby's cause it's funny.
Sweet water tavern.
We live across the street front.
So I've had enough of them every day I walk my dogs and I have to like fight
them for chicken wing bones.
Yeah,
that's kind of a nasty court or down there sometimes when there's like after
Lionsgate or Saint Andrews Hall concert or something.
So it's like,
if you can imagine like my docs and is feisty.
So I'm trying to like,
yeah.
And he's growling at me.
I'm on a chicken bone.
You got to let it go.
We spend a lot of time down there with some of us have clients and such around
General Motors and around the AD agency.
So we're always looking for good recommendations.
What do you think is the best lunch place around that area?
Tough man lunches.
So tough besides the stand by,
but you can see my doesn't open until four.
We don't have until five.
Five.
So yeah,
we're late.
We do late night,
so desserts til 2:00 AM.
Yeah.
And we do like,
we do chicken and dumplings from 12 to two.
Oh,
I didn't know.
So like there's like nice hot something to get until 2:00 AM because there's
really not a lot.
Yeah.
Um,
but lunch go cy.
Ty is really good.
Um,
I don't like,
I like the salads that they have at grand trunk.
We did two long trunk.
We'd spend a lot of time.
Yeah.
It's one of the few places.
It's often the apparatus room.
If you can get in his great lunch.
Okay.
I sit at the bar.
Yeah.
Semester.
Um,
but yeah,
there's just not a whole lot of places to have lunch downtown yet.
Like we're working on it.
Yeah.
We think that's a big opportunity.
Especially with companies like Microsoft and hopefully Amazon and obviously
Google moving down there.
Definitely.
Yeah.
It would prove it for,
it's all in the works,
man.
All that stuff.
It was like coming.
You're going,
I is there anything you want to reveal today here at Google and that plans that
like we want to do that.
Like that's in the,
cause there's,
they're literally like,
we all go to the desert.
Desert Oasis.
Coffee,
coffee.
Yeah.
To have to like have meetings and we're like,
this would be great if there was food.
Yeah.
And like there's only so many times you can eat it.
The little Mexican street on the corner.
It is good though.
It is good.
Yeah.
But when you've had,
I'm like,
okay,
we've all had their menu and we all are totally lazy and we get delivery at
stand by all of the time.
Like,
oh my God,
you guys,
we have to stop.
Like there's nothing healthy about anything that we're doing.
Do you think when Google moves down to Detroit,
you might come over and celebrity guests,
chef for us one day I said are a way we could get you to do that.
Yeah.
How many people do you have to serve?
Awesome.
Okay.
Well be about what,
120 at some point,
but 80 maybe at first.
We'll figure that out afterwards.
Yeah,
I can totally do that.
That's easy.
Okay,
awesome.
That's totally,
I think that concludes the interview.
It.
No,
just kidding.
Okay.
So why don't I stop talking.
There's a microphone over here.
Is there anyone with any questions for Rebecca?
So you talked about,
um,
maybe expanding a little bit outside of the standby.
Um,
are you looking to just kind of stay in that sort of midtown,
downtown area?
Are you looking at it,
uh,
any of the other neighborhoods?
For example,
like West village has some good development going on there.
Uh,
so just curious,
like what areas are you looking at?
We just bought a house over in that area,
a village.
We're super excited about it and there is no room right now in West village.
Everything is rented.
Yeah.
So West village is going to blow up here really soon with,
I know there's at least three or four restaurants opening.
Um,
my buddy Anthony Lombardo is opening his restaurant.
I can't remember the name of it right now.
Um,
but he actually moved over to midtown because he couldn't get in in West
village,
which is,
it's like,
um,
yeah,
we have,
there's still plenty of space downtown and I don't mind staying downtown.
I like it down there.
Um,
and I think downtown needs it.
I'm not a super huge suburb person.
I like to come out here to go shopping,
but I feel like there's,
there's lots of amazing stuff out here and there's a lot of call for some,
for new things.
So we're focusing,
both of us are focusing all of our energies kind of downtown.
Thank you.
That's good.
We need that.
That you're absolutely right.
If we could just figure out a way to get some of that shopping downtown and keep
him full of say down there Nordstrom's to move down to the
okay on it.
We had another question here.
So you mentioned that you're out the door at around nine 30 until 12.
Can you talk a little bit about what you do in your typical day from when you
start to finish?
So my day starts with um,
making sure that my soup,
my morning sous chef has like all the orders have come in.
It was all the stuff I actually ordered.
Um,
everybody is on the same page in that we have on prep projects with,
okay,
Burger me is here.
We petty those fresh everyday and making sure that that's done fries or blanched
by a certain time.
So by the time the cooks come in,
they're kind of out of their way.
And then by that time,
my other two sous chefs have made it in.
And normally at that point I have meetings and then I have meetings in and out
of the city.
So I'm kind of out and around all the time.
And the past couple of weeks,
months we have opened a cart out in the alley that we brought you guys some
snacks from,
but we're just some simple little like fun sayings.
Yeah.
Um,
so we,
it was,
I was focusing a lot on like,
okay we need equipment for that.
We need to get bids for equipment,
we need to figure out what we're going to serve it in.
Like how many people does,
does Jesse need to run that?
Um,
so I spent a lot of time doing that and we are also in the works of opening
another bar down the way down at the end on library street.
So that's been another focus cause I'm going to do soft serve ice cream in there
so
that will be safe.
Have you announced the name of that are still in the works?
I think it's called the Lux Lux or deluxe locks or something like that.
Looks less but that will be open sometime in March.
That's going to be really fun.
You um,
mentioned meetings outside of the city.
Is it,
I know you do a lot of sourcing from local farms and so is it usually related to
that?
So I do that.
I help,
um,
I consult for a couple of people.
The,
I'm just helping them get the restaurants open around and um,
menus and things like that.
I have,
um,
a couple of meetings with people that have that want to do private dinners and
then like every doctor's appointment and the world is over out here.
And then if anybody,
if you like,
the one thing that needs to come downtown desperately is a grocery store,
Nordstrom's and a grocery store and a non whole foods.
Whole foods is tiny and it gets
picked over and mentally quickly.
So if you need like Ziploc bags,
your host and wow,
CBS closest really quickly and that gets picked over really quickly.
So if you're like,
okay,
I need to like get actual staples of life,
you have to drive out to eight mile.
You mean sitting market doesn't have everything that you think?
Well,
it's also picked over quite quickly.
People know us very well.
Yeah,
they love my dogs.
Oh,
that's great.
Well.
Um,
I don't know if there's any other questions I would,
I'd love to have Rebecca do is talk a little bit about what she brought for us
today,
what you guys are going to enjoy.
And so we just changed the menu,
the dessert menu.
We,
Julian,
I love desserts.
So that's truly,
it's my sous chef in the back.
Um,
so we brought you what,
um,
our latest dessert that we put on the menu.
It is a sour cream,
old fashioned donut with dried cranberries,
pumpkin cheesecake and apple butter.
Wow.
And we brought some of the snacks that go out on the skip cart,
which is some spiced pecans with milk and dark chocolate world bend around it.
Are there any local companies or farms in this that go into this rest or recipes
that you brought today that you can hype up or tell us about?
So seedling farm has been,
um,
a form that I use in Chicago quite a bit.
And Pete was a tech guy that bought this farm from,
that has been around for over a hundred years.
But the,
I think the gentleman that owned it,
his family didn't want to keep it in the,
in like,
oh no,
I think he had anybody to um,
leave it to.
So Pete bought it and they live in Chicago and they drive all the way up to
grand haven every weekend to make sure that this farm continues to run.
And um,
wow.
It has heirloom pairs and like six different birds,
like no,
like 15 different varieties of apples.
Um,
ground cherries,
cherries,
figs,
he has all sorts of fun stuff.
So we get all of our apples from those guys and they ship them,
they truck them in from across the state.
That's cool.
Um,
we also buy from,
um,
I think it's cocoa Detroit and it is a company that goes around and helps little
farmers get their product to restaurants.
So we have one place to order from and they make sure that we get to use some
really awesome things.
And like some of these guys only grow one or two things,
but they go like,
this guy grows amazing beats or he has,
um,
really awesome Zucchini.
So we'll buy the flowers and all that stuff and it will come from,
from one person.
The guy's name is [inaudible].
It's really fun.
Yeah.
It's interesting because Chicago's not too far away so you can kind of share and
stay with the same farm seedling.
Sounds like maybe one of the ones that you did that with.
And what was annoying when we moved here as a lot of those farmers on the west
end of Michigan,
it's so much easier to go to Chicago that yeah,
there are lines that we'd have to drive to Detroit.
I'm like,
well Kenya,
you're in Michigan,
right?
Which is working out really awesome like they are,
which is great.
And has there been any,
any like a Michigan staple or products that's changed the way that you cook
because you were so surprised by the had all the cherries are the apples or
something.
I didn't realize that Michigan had nuts.
Oh,
so in southern Michigan there's like quite a few pecans and stuff,
which my dad did not farmer,
so that was like awesome.
Right.
Um,
but not really.
I mean growing up,
having a ton of stuff at my disposal,
I was super,
I'm always like super excited about cheese,
so I'm always finding local,
small artisanal cheese people.
There's a million good ones,
you know,
and I love it.
One of the local farm people like goes around and picks up cheese from all those
places.
So I'm like,
I'll,
I'll be on a two week waiting list.
I don't care.
I just want like one or two of those things that are available.
It's share with us who is the best artisanal cheese?
I can't remember the name of this farm.
They're right outside of Ann Arbor and they literally have like 20 goats.
Wow.
Less to figure that one.
Yeah,
we'll find out.
I'll figure it out.
Yeah.
But I was super excited to get their stuff,
but yeah.
Or I ordered it in there like it's a two week preorder and I was like,
dammit.
Yeah.
Good cheeses worth the wait for sure.
Absolutely.
Well thank you so much,
Rebecca.
Can we get a big round of applause.